And by now, this is a pretty standard modern-day fairy tale of girl posting on the internet,...
...the internet takes the girl by storm,...
...thousands of men voyage into the comment sections to ask for her hand in marriage.
She ignores all of them, starts a YouTube channel and keeps on building robots.
Since then, I've carved out this little niche for myself on the internet as an inventor of useless machines,...
...because as we all know, the easiest way to be at the top of your field is to choose a very small field.
I'm not an engineer.
I did not study engineering in school.
But, I was a super ambitious student growing up.
In middle school and high school, I had straight A's,...
...and I graduated at the top of my year.
On the flip side of that, I struggled with very severe performance anxiety.
And no, I did not accidentally burn our parents' house down.
The thing I'm writing about in the email and the thing I'm so upset about...
...is that I got a B on a math test.
So, something obviously happened between here and here.
One of those things was puberty.
Beautiful time indeed.
But moreover, I got interested in building robots,...
...and I wanted to teach myself about hardware.
But, building things with hardware, especially if you're teaching yourself,...
...is something that's really difficult to do.
It has a high likelihood of failure...
...and moreover, it has a high likelihood of making you feel stupid.
And that was my biggest fear at the time.